craig is with us in fargo north dakota
hi craig how are you
hey awesome thanks for taking my call
dave sure man what's up
um just looking for a little guidance
here i
am uh i'm in depth
like a lot of people um you know i've
been a long time listener and
i try and practice your what you preach
here and i
you know i'm about a hundred thousand
dollars in death
and i
you know i make close to a hundred
thousand a year but you know not all
that is
guaranteed i mean some other side
hustles and
commissions and all that uh um
single dad and just trying to
i mean i've tried the baby steps and
it's just you know just to
need to learn how to get some advice to
get that gazelle intensity you always
talk about
i mean it's
challenging craig what's keeping you
you've been listening for a while
and we talked about this last segment
what's keeping you from that gazelle
intensity
um i i don't know i mean i guess
i'm you know i guess i've paid off about
you know twelve thousand dollars in the
last three months
that's pretty good um um
so i i feel like i'm on the right track
but it's just
i want to be better for my kids right
and show them
how to learn some mistakes that i've
made in life so they don't ever have to
go through that
and these credit cards i mean
fortunately i'm getting down on those i
think
within a year i hopefully have those
taken care of but
i don't know it's just hard uh twelve
thousand dollars in three months is
forty eight thousand dollars a year
that means you're one hundred percent
debt free in two years
if you stay on that exact track okay
have you figured that part out i have
i have okay um you know i've i've had a
lot of
so then the only question is and the
only question is once you figure that
out
you say okay i'm gonna be debt free in
two years then the next question in my
mind if i'm you
is what can i do to get out of debt
faster
and that means there's only two sides of
the equation outgoing income
what can i do to get my income up well
you're a single dad and you're already
doing some side hustles maybe not a lot
i don't know maybe your side hustle
sucks maybe you need a new one i don't
know
something to think about and then the
the more
fired up you get the deeper you
sacrifice
and the deeper you sacrifice the faster
you get out of debt
and the only reason you would get that
fired up and sacrifice even deeper
is because you believe it's going to
work and you've really got
three good months of track record here
does that not feel pretty good
if it feels great dave it's you know
it's
money was the reason why i got divorced
so that's kind of the hard subject of
this
and unfortunately i still get along with
my ex-wife and that's actually their
relationship better now that
you know i was always putting money
first and it was always
that's all behind you you don't have to
talk to talk to her about this all
you've got to do is say
a hundred thousand dollars and forty
eight thousand dollars a year which is
four thousand dollars a month and i'm
gonna kick this thing's butt that's all
you gotta do
yeah you've got this heaviness over you
it's it's weird you've done pretty darn
good i mean three
12 grand in three months i mean that's
uh that's getting close to gazelle if
you think you can do more did you really
do that
yeah you really did that i mean
yeah i mean i mean i had some other you
know side hustles coming in right now
i'm gonna talk about that
if you really paid off four thousand
dollars a month three months in a row
then then there ought to be some
excitement about that and if
there's not and there's not because in
talking to you
you just sounded like you weren't dialed
in when you gave us those numbers
it changed the conversation he doesn't
believe he can do this
i think i think he's ashamed to do it
because it beat up the last marriage
there you go
so i don't care about your last marriage
it's over it's in the rearview mirror
i'm sorry i'm sorry you guys went
through that and i'm glad you're friends
now
whoopi dopey kick this kick this dadgum
death's butt man
that's right roll up you said i wanna do
this for my kids double up your fist and
punch this bully in the mouth
it's threatening your freaking family
it's time to get
fired up and get after it like it
matters and get that
thing get that i want to hear next time
i talk to you man i don't hear warrior
in your voice
i want to hear you you mad at the bully
yeah this thing's been it kicked your
marriage's butt
it's kicking your butt your you know
your tongue's dragging your tails
dragging everything else
so you need to pop this thing in the
head man you know bloody it snows
and you need to get fired up man you're
going to knock somebody down
that kind of thing is what we're looking
for here because
in your voice your numbers are much more
successful
than your voice tone and word choice
which both said my tail's dragging i
don't know if i can do this and it's
kind of hard now
that's what he sounded like correct
exactly and you know and instead
your numbers are like yeah rocky you
know your numbers were great
your numbers were rudy man which by the
way craig when dave asked you
how you feel about it that was the first
time in the call where your tone
changed and your pulse kind of increased
and i'll tell you what i'm going to
prescribe for you
i think you need to to the extent that
your kids understand it
if they're a little bit older i tell
them what you've done and how hard
you're working
and then and let them get in on it and
let them see the commitment you're
making and then i think you need some
great peers around you
yeah john people that are gonna get
excited for you here
jump in ramsey plus i'll give you a
one-year subscription to it jump in
there
and go through the financial peace
videos but more most importantly get on
the ask a coach
and most importantly get in some of the
communities the virtual communities
and start sharing and get some people
around you that are jazzing you man
that's right
you need a little bit of a cattle prod
that that coach that just yells at you
and says get it
yeah you know yeah he needs to feel the
affirmation
of the sacrifice and right now it feels
like he's so lonely those numbers should
be a
attaboy to you and they don't seem to
have time party time they don't seem to
be you ought to be going touchdown man i
just scored three three freaking
touchdowns
in a row four thousand four thousand
four thousand
that's man that's twelve thousand
dollars in three months that's pretty
stinking good
yes you know making a hundred grand
that's that that's
i mean he's not he really is living on a
beans and rice budget to do that
it's pretty close to gazelle to me yes i
realize it yeah i just want to hear it
in your voice and i want to hear it in
your belief
and hear that hope take root so yeah
hold on kelly i'll pick up we'll get you
signed up for ramsey plus and we're
gonna walk with you brother you can do
this man you can do it
yes this is the dave ramsey show